it looks like there's an epic throwdown
fight oh life listen sometimes with
family it can hit the fans there's no
way that you are going to have real
healing
and coming together coming to jesus
moment and ain't going to hit the
ceiling and that's what happened well
first of all you probably have heard
this 15 million times but you are good
tv am i yes i should do tv you should do
tv because you are good tv oh thank you
well the premiere you know of your new
show you've got the new book your very
first book yes lots going on you're
newly engaged good year for you it
really is yeah it really is everything
is happening right now and it's meant to
be it just feels right yeah you feel
like you've grown into porsha absolutely
you know the book pursuit of porsche
that's what it means it's in pursuit of
my
best self my truest self
and at this moment i feel powerful in
the confidence that i have
from whatever
good bad indifferent just being human
and getting to this point i feel your
journey hasn't always been the smoothest
and you talk about that in the book and
you share some really personal stories
like throughout your life what what made
you say okay i'm gonna write this and
it's no holds barred i'm given
everything so around the time of the
pandemic starting and everybody kind of
just being locked in you really start to
think about what's important to you and
self-reflecting and honestly at this
point i've realized to know yourself is
to love yourself and i got to know
myself but that journey is my testimony
and
when it relates to the show i've been on
tv for 10 years you know a lot of my
personal life is out there yeah a lot of
my personal life is out there a lot of
my followers feel like they truly know
me yeah but once i really took and
looked at my journey and
uh what it has meant to me and becoming
who i am today i felt like it was almost
doing
the world an ingested to not go deeper
and give that other layer of who i am
and how i got to where i am today i
wanted to be honest because i wanted the
book to be effective in its purpose and
the purpose is is to really go dive in
and look at those patterns you know
those pitfalls this book could be also
called girl i got you because it's
almost like a step-by-step guide for
women of what not to do in some
situations that is what it's supposed to
be so here's the thing
a lot of choices in my life um i had a
very supportive mother who i was very
close to but a part of some of those
decision making that i did not run by
hers because i didn't want to disappoint
her right so therefore i was handling
things on my own i didn't have a big
sister so honestly in this book i would
love for a young woman or young man to
read
these situations that i found myself in
and stop the pattern before they have to
go through what i went through let's go
back to some of the early times when you
talked about because you did like
chronicle specific things that really
shaped who you were becoming as a woman
the first one was you talked about a
boyfriend who sexually assaulted you
reading that i felt like i was on that
journey i could almost see it when you
said it was so dark there were no lights
i didn't know his eyes were black like i
almost felt like i could be there with
you
that had to have been i mean terrifying
number one but then also to have to
relive that
so
i decided to relive that moment because
there are so many women
who
have lived it and are still silent
and even me until 40 have been silent on
that
and
when i wrote the book i was very very
very detailed to take you into that
moment
and you know actually when i did the
audio for the book i couldn't even read
that part my sister had to come in and
read that part of the book for me
i wasn't strong enough then to stop this
pattern
i wasn't strong enough even two years
ago to write about or face this pattern
it wasn't until i had therapy and i
truly wanted to just face some of those
demons
and forgive myself
because i had done a lot of blaming
myself as a victim uh blaming that
person and
honestly writing this book was like the
longest therapy session ever
well can we talk about what's been
making a lot of headlines r kelly so the
patterns of of picking toxic men
led you to r kelly
i mean i was in the book you were
talking about you felt like it was very
innocent and part of me was like was she
that naive or what was it something was
it the fame that blinded what was it
that led you there and then actually led
you back a few times i didn't see myself
i didn't know myself
and like i said i only saw myself
through someone else's eyes so i just
saw myself as a young pretty girl who
could sing that he was interested in so
when you read the book i start out from
my childhood and i talk about moments
where i have
literally
and figuratively been trapped
by people um your dad telling you if you
got in trouble go in this room and don't
come out until i tell you right right
so and in those cases
it brought me back to that practice of
being obedient
and feeling like you don't have any
other option
so it was really when i think about that
situation as a grown woman i realized
how warped my mentality was of who i was
and what is supposed to happen to me and
was not supposed to happen to me it's
almost like if you have a child who
grows up and they not me but if you have
someone who's grown up and they've been
abused and then they tell someone they
don't even realize it was abused right
um that's kind of where i was i didn't
realize
that here i am continuing this same act
over and over and over again so when i
found myself
trapped yeah it was a mental
trap i'm sure you think about this
because you i know she's your world your
daughter yeah in writing this did you
think about she's gonna one day read
this
and what do i want her to learn
from this ultimately if something ever
happens to me
and i have this book left i hope it
blesses her to be smarter in situations
i hope she can stop the pattern no
matter how it develops so i would love
for her to be able to read this book and
see that her mommy was a survivor
she could be a survivor her mommy was
smart her mommy was fearless she just
didn't know at these times and she got
taken advantage of and she made some
mistakes but she can learn it quicker
than me
why would i remember that small bit
well it must have struck her in a way it
was shade that's what it was so after
nine years
ten nine ten years once you decided you
were going to walk away from housewives
boo by the way
um you talked about this in the first
episode of your new show when i told my
sister i was moving to atlanta she was
like
what
nobody has been able to get me to move
from duluth my home for me has been a
manifestation of my independence this
move for me is a believe in porsche move
was your decision based on
the new relationship you were in and the
connection that it had to
last season of housewives
no no no um i had said that we were
worried that the other ladies were gonna
come for you and talk about that they
come for me every season they come from
every season but in actuality i have
started preparing to semi-retire at 40
about two to three years ago
i have a great finance team i have a
great manager and
once i had my daughter i knew i want to
spend more time with her okay and so i
had started preparing that it just so
happened i don't know just
divine
purpose that at 40 this all happened so
at 40 at round that reunion i realized i
said you know what this is this is the
moment this is the moment to take this
break so i had made that decision right
after reunion had let everybody know
around that time of course no one wanted
to hear it right but um i had already
made that decision prior to even getting
with simon okay but of course when you
have when you break the internet like
this everybody's going to want to know
what the other girls have to say and
what's that going to look like so of
course i get that everybody would think
that that goes together but it's
actually not um in my family show we
dive into it way more than i think a lot
so does that mean the door is not closed
the door is open i like that there you
go the door is not vaulted it is there
is no vault on it it's not locked but
what are you thankful for now that you
have kind of removed yourself from that
lane of reality television space and
time to just be porsha
yeah space and time just before sure
well let's talk about this good space
that you're in uh with your new
relationship with simon okay because you
know y'all made headlines you talk about
breaking the internet that picture of
simon and yes yes it was a wrap yeah
child folks had their theories we were
dissecting it blowing the picture up
looking like oh they're showing itself
online i'm like okay y'all you ought to
create all kind of narratives yes yes
but people came for you and simon on
social media they really did and so what
do you think
is the biggest misconception about your
relationship the biggest misconception
is that someone would have done
something to hurt someone yeah um or
that you know someone was obligated to
something else and anything was broken i
mean this is just a story of adults
making adult decisions decisions for
themselves and the show portions family
matters it really does dive into the
details of how everything happens so i
mean listen i know the optics i mean
when i was on housewives it is what it
is right we set up different things not
set up ads and fake but just what's a
natural way to bring someone around and
stuff like that so it can make you think
other something other than what the
reality is yeah to set the record
straight you're saying you were not
friends with simon's ex
no well i want it to be i want it to be
but it's a common practice that if
you're bringing someone new in they have
to be introduced by someone yes yes i
think one of the things that people
talked about too and your family talked
about it last night on the show was that
this relationship moved really quick
you know and dennis talked about it it
did it did yeah it moved really quickly
yeah so why do you think that it went
from like 0 to 60 in like 3.5 seconds
because i met a man who was at the same
place that i was at the same time okay
mentally wanted the same thing
spiritually and in love you have to
think about for me to get to a place to
walk away from the real housewives of
atlanta walk away from dish put porsche
first and really concentrate on what i
want to do in my purpose faith walk when
you meet someone else at that exact same
place it's a powerful force
so as soon as we started talking and
you're talking to a man who has done a
hundred something or a hundred what does
it would just always say 175 hours of
therapy and has truly truly looked at
all of his mistakes and have turned
around to be for the better when you
meet someone in that space you are going
to be
in kind you know like company he didn't
give you an ultimatum of do housewives
or have this relationship that way do
you think the porsche now will let
somebody give them all tomato okay
housewives has paid my bills for 10
years ain't no man ever going to come in
my space and tell me what to do with
with my career so absolutely not i will
say and and you acknowledged this in the
book and i thought it was um really nice
when you were saying thank you to people
you did say thank you dennis for being
an incredible father absolutely yeah
absolutely you know even though our
relationship did not work out
it's just it doesn't mean he's a bad
person right it doesn't just meant that
he and i weren't meant to be in a
romantic relationship but i do feel like
co-parenting works best when you can
look at someone like family and i always
wanted my daughter to have a close
relationship with her father we girls
need our dads or father figures
and i love the dad that he is for pilar
okay last question um because the
trailer gave us some moments and one of
those was it looks like there's an epic
throw down fight yeah now all of a
sudden he's at the table and he's a mr
tough guy we're interested out of our
business
[Applause]
i'll take mentally stable for 200 alex
thank you
and ends with you like kind of screaming
and you know being restrained
what happens
oh life listen sometimes with family it
can hit the fan yeah there's no way that
you are going to have real healing
and coming together coming to jesus
moment and ain't going to hit the
ceiling that's true and that's what
happened that was a part of the process
that we were going through so everybody
was kind of it was it was everywhere
okay everybody was everywhere
and everybody's good though i like
seeing the new members of your family
and your friends so everybody isn't that
fun yeah it is like i feel like everyone
has known me for so long but like to see
my sister my aunts and people you never
knew
um who are so close to me and know so
much about me and not afraid to speak on
me right yeah it's fun
[Music]